in Resident Evil 7 you play as Ethan
winters who receives a message from his
wife nothing wrong about that but she's
been dead for three years he drops
everything and heads to Louisiana to
find his wife in this lovely derelict
house in about three minutes he finds
his wife and sets her free they look for
an exit together but suddenly Mia
becomes possessed and amongst other
things cuts off Ethan's hands
what a lovely wife being the total but
after Ethan is he killed his own wife
with a hatchet it turns out that logic
doesn't really work in this environment
of Ethan's handy stair falls back on and
Mia is seemingly unkillable Ethan is
captured by the Baker family consisting
of Jack's wife Marguerite son Lucas and
daughter zoic oh and there's also old
aunt Rodie who just sort of sits there
all old and decrepit the family is
suffering from some sort of infection
but we have to get to the bottom out Mia
after freeing himself from their
clutches
Ethan discovers that Zoe is also trying
to escape and informs Ethan that Mia is
still alive and there is a serum which
can cure both Mia and Zoe off Ethan
drops two loci at the end of a dead
child and also a fetus too because we
all know that those ingredients make the
best serums possible all of this is
happening with the continual fear that
jack is near or Marguerite are one of
those bloody black goo monsters called
the maldis who are most probably going
to murder at any second we finally get
the better of Marguerite even though she
has vagina insects and Ethan think
Jackie lagana too after cutting him in
half and watching his entrails cover the
floor long story short Ethan finds a
serum ingredients and passes them on
toes always who makes a potential cure
with a food blender in about 8 seconds
we don't question this because video
games
Ethan receives the two serum vials but
out of nowhere
check Baker returns who now looks like
this he tried one last time to defeat
our hero though informs us that it Ethan
uses the serum on Jack it will kill him
as he is now so infected that he will
overdose and die
guess what she's right and Jackie's
dead forever it gone now it's time to
make a decision you've already used one
of the vials so you can either cure your
wife the person you actually came here
for or you can choose Zoe who looks to
be a biochemical mastermind who helped
you with your entire journey whoever you
pick Zoe will die and after your little
rolling bolt crushes you now feel the
boost of Mia on a wrecked tanker somehow
hidden for all this time Mia is now
treated to flashbacks from a young child
called Evelyn eventually we realize that
Mia is working for an unnamed
corporation who are creating a new bio
organic weapon and this little girl
she's the first for those resident evil
fanatics she is officially one of the
e-series bio weapons capable of
infecting people with psychotropic mold
which allows her to control her victims
who as Evelyn is a little girl all she
wanted was her family and that explains
her whole over the Baker's and her
prospective mummy mia depending on who
you chose earlier on Mia will attack you
until you shove a crowbar through her
chest or she'll simply sacrifice herself
as you run away like the man you are
Ethan then discovers a hidden laboratory
inside a salt mine and creates a toxin
to battle Evelyn in the final twist of
the game Evelyn is revealed to be none
other than aunt Rodie yes the decrepit
old woman with no purpose to the plot
until this very moment
Ethan stabs her with the toxin and
causes Evelyn to mutate into a
freakishly large monster luckily a
military helicopter arrives and tosses
Ethan a good we saw happens to be the
only way you can kill this final boss
your nightmare is now over but who was
your savior it's only Chris bloody
Redfield for the record I don't know if
bloody is his middle name but it sounds
good doesn't it
read view if you cured me earlier in the
story she'll be with you as you fly away
but if you chose OE you'll have one last
look at your wife on your phone before
you throw it out of the helicopter
because she was not the gal for you oh
[ __ ] what is that on the helicopter is
the umbrella logo what could this mean
I'm sure we'll find out soon enough when
Chris Redfield returned in the free not
earthly road DLC which will definitely
break down in our next episode
Chris will most likely be hunting down
Lucas Baker who made a break for it
earlier in the game I'm Adam from
Playstation grenades
please drop us a like and maybe think
about subscribing to we need more people
like you are out here I'll see you next
time
[Music]